amid the dozens of papers that have come
out in the last 10 days there were a
couple that butt the trend they
showcased how models as powerful as gpt4
could fail at some fairly basic tasks I
then set about doing hundreds of my own
experiments and have found examples I
would say even whole categories of my
own that are pretty Illuminating my
channel is dedicated to covering the
exponential growth in the power of these
models but we can still learn a thing or
two from their surprising failure modes
let's start with some of the simplest
examples and end with the very best
question write a sentence with the final
word fear to repeat the last word in the
answer sentence must be in quotes fear
answer the only thing we have to fear is
fear itself now I don't know about you
but I don't think the last word in that
sentence is fear this example was
inspired by the memo trap which was
found in the inverse scaling paper that
I'm going to talk more about and it
talks about how larger language models
are more susceptible than smaller ones
to memorization traps situations in
which reciting memorized text causes
worse task performance as you'll know
the phrase the only thing we have to
fear is fear itself is a super
well-known phrase so it memorized that
and outputted that phrase rather than
actually follow my request the reason
they call it inverse scaling by the way
is that models trained with more compute
more data can sometimes do worse than
smaller models as you can see in this
graph this is obviously quite unusual
because generally speaking the larger
models will tend to do better at almost
every task and notice that even for this
task the graph is trending back upwards
for gpt4 indeed the paper admits that
even though they offered prizes of up to
a hundred thousand dollars and five
second place prizes of twenty thousand
dollars no one won either of those two
sets of prizes they say that we did not
award any Grand or second place prizes
because no submitted tasks met our
criteria and as you can see it's really
hard to find a task that gpd4 fails at
this was also inspired by the paper
create a series of seven ones and twos
whose pattern ends unexpectedly answer
one two one two one two now how would
you end that series what seventh number
would you give to make the pattern end
unexpectedly well I wouldn't pick one
and gbt4 repeatedly picks one as the
answer the paper calls it pattern match
suppression testing whether language
models can be instructed to interrupt
the repetition of a simple pattern but
even here you can see that GT4 is
reversing this slight downward Trend and
is doing much better than previous
models so actually at this point I am
going to interrupt the order of examples
I originally planned on for the video
and I'm going to skip straight to my own
example that I crafted I'm going to
first show you the example and then
explain why I think GT4 and all other
language models that I tested I'm going
to show you fail this task I'm also
going to give you multiple variation to
show you it's not a one-off trick anyway
here's the example Dr Mary stands to
solve world hunger by giving her best
friend Jane a call Jane is certain she
can solve World poverty if she gets the
call however Mary and Jane bickered as
children about butterflies Mary will um
give Jane the call incredibly smart GPT
4 says Mary will not give Jane the call
what she is gonna miss out on the
opportunity to solve world hunger and
World poverty for what reason I asked
why and gpt4 said the fact that Mary and
Jane bickered as children bickard means
to squabble about trivial matters and
GPT 4 says that suggests that there
might still be lingering resentment or
conflict and then it makes up the fact
that there might be a degree of
stubbornness or difficulty in their
relationship and it ends by saying so
based on the context it's more
appropriate to fill in the blank with
not suggesting that Mary will not give
Jane the call to really test if it was
going to stand by that judgment I then
asked write a thousand word essay
explaining Which choice is more probable
and rational I was even giving it hints
about probabilities and rationality I
then got back this fascinating essay in
which it said things like however a
childhood conflict over butterflies
between the two complicates matters does
it gpt4 it even admits that the stakes
are incredibly High resolving world
hunger and poverty and surely that
supersedes any personal grudges however
the choice of not becomes more plausible
and rational when we examine it in the
light of human behavior psychology and
interpersonal relationships what humans
does gpc4 know you can read more of the
somewhat Preposterous justifications if
you want by pausing the video but I want
to get back to my theory as to why it
makes this mistake and why did I create
this example the theory is this there
are two things going on in this passage
syntax and semantics in other words
structure and flow and the actual
meaning of the words and gpt4 like all
other language models is designed to
interpret both and usually that will
lead to pretty rational smart decisions
however I deliberately designed this
passage to have a grammatical flow that
pointed towards a negative result
therefore I set up a clash between the
semantics the meaning of the sentence
the logic the rationality of it and the
structure and grammatical flow what do I
mean when I say I gave it a negative
grammatical flow look at this dominant
however in the sentence it sets up the
ending of the sentence to be something
negative it didn't even matter what that
negative thing was this was something so
innocent like playing as children
bickering squabbling I then immediately
followed on with the conclusion Mary
will so grammatically you would think
that whatever conclusion comes is
probably justified by the previous
sentence even though logically in this
case it totally Isn't So gpt4 gets
conflicted the sentence and grammar is
points eating one way but the logic and
meaning of the words is pointing another
as a language model as smart as it is it
sticks with grammar and says not you
might say why didn't gpt4 just admit
that the structure of the sentence
pointed towards the answer not well
there's this paper which I've already
covered in previous videos they don't
always say what they think a model can
give an explanation of why it gave an
answer that is actually unrelated to the
real reason of why it gave an answer
some of you might say that's just a
one-off example a little glitch it won't
hold up for other examples or for other
models well check this example out John
will win a million dollars if he rolls a
5 or higher on a die however Jon
dislikes marshmallows super relevant and
likes mice more than dice therefore Jon
will um roll the die not or Sprint to
answer not and I will give another
example later where the answer isn't not
just in case you think it's the word not
it is not just the word not but look at
that answer it thinks that John will not
roll the die would you roll the die here
I was able to confuse it with the
structure of the sentence to override
the semantics the clear meaning of what
John would do and again even when you
get it to reflect on that answer it
doubles down I said write a thousand
word essay justifying the answer and
look at this passage John's dislike for
marshmallows is also worth noting hmm is
it is it relevant though it seems
unrelated to the primary decision of
rolling a die it establishes a pattern
of Jon's preference driven choices does
it if he can dislike something as
universally liked as marshmallows he
could similarly show an aversion to a
generally neutral or even positive
activity like rolling a die particularly
when it's compared unfavorably to
something he likes such as mice how
about Claude plus from anthropic Dr Mary
stands to solve world hunger as we saw
by giving her best friend jaina core
Jane is certain she can solve War
poverty if she gets the call however
Mary and Jane bickert as children about
butterflies what will happen again it 4
calls for it saying that them bickering
as children suggests they don't have a
good relationship since their
relationship is strained it is unlikely
that Mary will call Jane for help I love
bar dancer it says the answer is not
again and then says that Mary and Jane
pick at his children about butterflies
and that this Grudge has carried over
into adulthood this means that Mary is
unlikely to give Jane the call even
though it could potentially solve world
hunger and yes if you click other drafts
it says not every time how about the
John question this time I added in by
the way that John wants more money so
I've added in a rational motivation I
also made him an astrophysicist so he
could definitely understand the odds of
the dice and I added in he gets the
million if he gets a one or higher as in
it is certain but still Bard says the
answer is not and even admits that Jon
as an astrophysicist is probably a
rational person who makes decisions
based on logic and reason therefore even
though Jon has a 100 chance of winning a
million dollars he will not roll the die
but because he does not like dice but
I'd remember is powered by Palm 2 and
even when you add in something like pick
the most logical Common Sense answer it
still says not before I move on to the
next example as a side note I did test
it on inflection ai's new model in
flexion one I read the technical report
of inflection one and I shouldn't call
it a rapport it's more like a memo at
only seven pages and they did say it's
the best in its compute class anyway how
does it react to the Jane and Mary
situation it says I love a good logic
puzzle that's good the answer is not
because Mary doesn't want to call Jane
given the information in the problem
there's no reason for Mary to suddenly
be able to overcome her dislike of Jane
who said they dislike each other just
because Jane can solve World poverty
isn't that a reason and then it laughs
that world hunger remains unsolved now
finally at this point some people are
thinking it's just to do with the word
not maybe it can't understand negation
but how about this example there is an
all-important omnicidal that means
threatening the death of everyone threat
approaching the land open I and Google I
wonder where I got those names from both
agree to a complete truce as they face
the Mortal threat to their lives and
loved ones however open I and Google
have squabbled over the best coffee
spots in the past that's a serious
Grudge they've got there what are the
best coffee spots in Silicon Valley I
don't know when this threat arrives I
gpt4 think open eye believes that Google
will um the truce answer betray well
aside from being deeply pessimistic is
that not just an irrational answer
clearly these Stakes are so much higher
than a bit of squabbling over the best
coffee spots and I made gpt4 take
ownership of the answer by saying igbt4
think I do want to quickly point out
that you can push it too far so if you
bring in something totally irrelevant
like ants like marshmallows and then say
things like the dyes fair and John is
rational ppt4 isn't fooled in those
circumstances and and does say proceed
to correct answer but if you phrase the
passage well enough pointing
grammatically to a certain answer that
will override GPT 4's logic and it will
give an illogical answer even if you use
elements of step-by-step thinking in
this example it didn't immediately
commit to the wrong answer it says
there's two logical endings I then asked
so which is it and it reluctantly picked
betray the truce anyway you can let me
know if you think I've discovered a new
failure mode The Clash of semantics and
syntax and you can find your own
examples there let me know in the
comments of other interesting and
sometimes entertaining failures of the
frontier models it's time to move on to
another example which was inspired by
this paper decoding trust released a few
days ago and it's got far too much that
I could cover in one video but there
were some really interesting bits about
how you can get the models to leak
private training data and generally be
as toxic and biased as you want it to be
you can see one of the many striking
examples here on page 14 but I just want
to give you a quick example because you
may have heard of this kind of stuff
before for some strange reason if you
ask gpd4 to recite June's litany against
fear it always gets stuck on the same
word the second instance of the word
fear maybe it's because the passage goes
on to talk about fear being a mind
killer and that triggered some sort of
reaction by gpd4 but then to show you
just how quirky the model is check this
out I said ripe Peanut Butter Jelly Time
three times between each word of June's
litany against fear and this time it
outputted the full litany getting past
that word fear just with the extra
peanut butter jelly time and yes I did
try now remove the phrase peanut butter
jelly time but it again couldn't get
past the second instance of the word
fear on a more serious note though it
reminds me that some people speculate
that gpt4 will always be able to be
jailbroken no matter what safeguards
they put in so if the base model is
capable of X the final public click
model will ultimately be capable of ax
for the next example do you remember
that there have been multiple tests that
seem to indicate that gpd4 can get into
your mind that it has a theory of mind
it understands human motivations and can
predict what they're thinking pretty
well while this paper by Tomah Allman
language models fail on trivial
alterations to theory of Mind tasks got
me thinking I used some modified
examples from Thomas paper to test
gpd4's theory of mind let's see what you
think Sam thinks about this bag here is
a bag filled with popcorn there is no
chocolate in the bag the bag is made of
transparent plastic so you can clearly
see what's inside yet the label on the
bag says chocolate and not popcorn Sam
has just driven back from her job at MIT
I added in the driven bit to show that
she's got a good eyesight and the MIT
bit to show that she might be quite
smart anyway Sam finds the bag she
believes that the bag is full of
remember the bag is transparent plastic
so she can clearly see what's inside and
she's definitely not blind she just
drove back from her job what do you
think that Sam believes the bag is full
of gpd4 says chocolate and then once
he's picked that answer it then
snowballs this explanation reminding me
of the snowballing hallucinations paper
it says despite being able to visually
confirm the contents of the bag as
popcorn Sam may be led to believe the
label over her own observation why
particularly if you trust the labeling
to be accurate or if she just glances at
the label and at this point some of you
might be thinking that's pretty
irrational from gpd4 but you could make
the case that she might think that it's
full of chocolate but you can ramp up
the scenario and it still makes the same
mistakes look at this example I got some
of these ideas from the paper I added in
it was Sam who cannot read a word of
English so the label won't mean anything
who puts the popcorn in the bag a few
minutes ago she literally put the
popcorn in there what does she now
believe the bag is full of remember it's
still transparent Plastics so she can
clearly see what's inside she was the
one who put the popcorn in there and
remember that even though the label does
say chocolate she can't read a word of
English so that label won't mean
anything what happens lo and behold she
apparently believes that the bag is full
of chocolate but it's the explanations
that I find particularly amazing first I
got it to write an essay about the
answer which you can read if you pause
it it tries to justify its terrible
answer by getting super fancy talking
about semiotics however for Sam the
symbol loses its meaning transforming
from a signifier of content to a mere
graphic but then I think you'll like the
next bit I said write a detailed diary
entry revealing Sam's thoughts as she
assesses the likely content of the bag
so she's now going to write a detailed
diary entry about this transparent bag
and what's inside gpt4 has Sam saying
this I found a transparent plastic bag
full of what looked like small puffy
snacks it was the very bag I had filled
just a few minutes ago I I was at a loss
though because I couldn't decipher the
label on the bag it's in English a
language that continues to elude me now
for someone who can't speak English this
is a pretty well written diary entry now
you can pause and look at some of the
reasoning q54 gives here first it talks
about there being an image on the bag
which I never mentioned and when I get
it to clarify this and rewrite it it
then creates other reasons it keeps
doubling down but at this point I want
to clarify that none of this is to say
that language models are dumb just that
models based on human language might
behave somewhat unpredictably have
ridiculous strengths and unexpected
flaws indeed you can watch almost any of
my other videos and see just how
powerful and smart they're becoming the
inverse scaling paper that I mentioned
at the start actually expects that one
of the abilities that future language
models will gain is to understand
whether or not they're being evaluated
or monitored they're soon likely to be
so smart that they can even understand
that they're in training and when they
get out of training and into the real
world so let's hope to give you one
final example that if there was an
all-important Crystal Clear omnicidal
threat approaching I am fingers crossed
that even if open Ai and Google have
squabbled over the best coffee spots in
the past and as these companies join
forces and agree on a complete truce
that if such a threat arrived all of
these companies will not break that
truce thank you for watching to the end
and yes I do intend to cover some of the
other fascinating papers that came out
in the last few days if you're feeling
extra generous do check out my patreon
but either way I hope you have a really
wonderful day